mannschaft muss immer grün und rot zu
werden
ich sagte nur baby
[Musik]
der august behindere kaum so schlimm
finde so davis bis zu meiner größe gibt
es fünf
also ich höre bühne und stirbt
[Musik]
die heitere unter anderem 16 und mit dem
textbuch lehre ganz einfach und klappt
[Musik]
b
was ist dann passiert los raus mit der
sprache jetzt wurden sie bearbeitet
waren
aber wie kommen ihre fingerabdrücke an
das taschentuch ist die frage nicht
sicher schwierigkeiten theorie dir bin
ich zwar ein bisschen wie der
wissenschaften und der g10 eindruck dass
die hätten wir wieder cancelled wird und
und und die neuen speicher dass ich so
so hauptschwierigkeit
wahrlich
ich sage dir
in dieser nacht vor der hahn kräht dass
du mich dreimal verleugnet
und wenn ich auch mit dir sterben müsste
ich werde dich nicht verleugnen
ja
wir nehmen die überzeugungsarbeit
leisten dass die jedoch bildungsweg sind
ja schon mächtig